Black Canary we could use more women
yeah super girl for that same reason and
it's nice I've got a family Superman
cetana cuz she could just come in and
just make crazy stuff happen yeah scary
having that sword around I understand I
understand I love the China yes good
call the fishnets right I don't know is
that what I mean hey I think we just
create a different dynamic you know when
you're following the news at all when
Davina each of these characters gets
together because we all have like
one-on-one time with in the movie except
for Henry because he's dead he is
one-on-one time with himself and it's
interesting just to see the different
dynamics I would just add a different
flavor to the to the soup we got Justice
League gumbo there could be someone in
the Green Lantern or who could be a
woman there's no reason why a woman
can't get the ring wheesh a woman with a
fish head this is about to spark major
contrabass me to do a video for some of
the extra characters for the Justice
League Universe the stars were talking
about Justice League - not Justice
League one so no spoilers for Justice
League but when they were talking about
Black Canary talking about Supergirl
talking about more mera they're talking
about the next Justice League movie so
if there were any doubts that they were
planning on doing that these are the
actors talking about the characters that
are in contention for that movie now
obviously there's a lot of Justice
League they got cut out I will do
deleted scenes videos like I just did
for Thor Ragnarok after it comes out so
people have a chance to see it first but
what's happening right now is they're
deciding what that second Justice League
movie is going to be in which characters
they're going to introduce to it because
you have the opportunity to bring in all
these other people so Supergirl I know
there's been a long-standing theory that
she's been on earth for a while and
there's sort of some tie-in comics for
Batman V Superman and Man of Steel as
well as some stuff that appeared during
the Man of Steel movie but if you
haven't seen it in a while the idea is
is the Kryptonian scoutship the Superman
finds has an open pod and has been there
on earth for a long law
time so if there was a super girl or
she's been there and left a long time
ago so obviously the twist is is that in
most modern retellings of the super girl
story she comes to earth after Superman
has been Superman for a while the
expanded material like the comics that
were released around those movies just
told you a little bit more about that
there's gave you the idea that
Kryptonians had visited earth before
Superman
so yes there was a Supergirl you can
choose to believe that she's still alive
in present day but her the stars they
actually want to bring her into the
second Justice League movie if Supergirl
is still somewhere near a Yellow Sun
she's effectively ageless so they can
bring on anybody that looks like
whatever they want they could do a
really young version of the characters
they could do a much more older but sure
version of the character but talking
about Black Canary obviously they have
the Gotham City sirens movie so that
just anybody that's fair game for the
movies right now like they have all the
Harley Quinn stuff that's happening you
know built around her poison ivy
Catwoman definitely guaranteed for that
movie but I think if they were going to
include Black Canary as Black Canary
during a Justice League movie it'd be a
relatively minor appearance and because
there's just so many things going on
during Justice League this first movie I
think they'll try to take the same
approach with the other expanded Kanin
characters in the second Justice League
movie so the most Black Canary we would
see would be just like a brief scene of
her using her power or one of the other
characters bumps into someone and that
someone just happens to be Dinah Lance
inside an office somewhere but talking
about the Green Lantern's I definitely
think we're gonna see Green Lantern
during that second Justice League movie
when they're talking about female Green
Lantern though that's probably Jessica
Cruz because you could do one of the
nonhuman Green Lantern's and they will
do that in the movies eventually but
because they've already teased the idea
for that Green Lantern movie is gonna be
a lethal weapon with Hal Jordan and Jon
Stewart I think if we see Jessica Cruz
pop up during the movie it'll be a
relatively minor appearance and she
won't have the ring yet like she'll be a
future Green Lantern because that's sort
of the way it happened in the comics too
but you kind of get the idea they're
just teasing that there's going to be a
lot more female big-name characters
coming so obviously Gotham City sirens
is probably the first big film for that
the Harley Quinn movie I know there's a
lot of confusion with what's going on
with that character because supposedly
there's the jared leto version of the
character that might come back during
the Suicide Squad sequel then there's
the rumor of the Leonardo DiCaprio
spin-off movie so who knows what's gonna
happen with that but I think the only
thing you can count on is that the
actors that have appeared before will
come back and what'll probably happen is
is they'll just shift the movies around
a little bit like Suicide Squad too will
eventually happen with a different
director and a different creative team
they're definitely going to do more
films centered around Harley Quinn
Gotham City sirens is just the easiest
way to do that so between those the main
Justice League films
the other big Batman films you just have
a really big opportunity for these
female characters to run around so when
they say Supergirl Black Canary mera
they're just intending on using them
more across the universe but obviously
Mira probably works best in concert with
an Aquaman based storyline so you see a
whole bunch of her during the Aquaman
movie and without doing spoilers for her
storyline during Justice League I'm just
expecting them to do a lot more with her
when we get to the second Justice League
movie because I think they spent a lot
of this first movie figuring out how her
powers work before they got to the
Aquaman movie they sort of refined that
so I totally trust James Wan he probably
found a really cool way to do aqua
Kinesis and we'll just see a lot more of
that when we get to the second Justice
League movie but they don't officially
have a date for that yet that could
shift around a little bit so we'll talk
more about that after Justice League
comes out and I can actually start
talking about the spoiler extra
characters that they included in the
movie because there's a lot of stuff
happening with Justice League but you
can't really talk about it without
getting into spoilers so I'm allowed to
post my review video Wednesday night so
that's when that will post that'll be
non spoilery then also posting my easter
egg videos post credits all that kind of
stuff starting Thursday night and Friday
but let me know in the comments which
other female characters do you want to
see them do in the big Justice League
films forget about the expanded films
just Justice League so what will happen
next is is a new crossover teaser for
the big four-way crossover just drops so
I'll do a video for that they also
announced a Lord of the Rings TV series
is actually going to happen now they
just confirmed that Amazon is gonna do
this insane high budget TV series so
I'll explain what's going on with that
the time period that it's set during in
the obvious comparison to Game of
Thrones because anytime you're talking
about doing a big high
fantasy series you can't avoid comparing
it to what Game of Thrones has done so
that'll probably post early Tuesday
morning but there's a new round of that
Justice League ticket giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video
congratulations to the winner from the
last video the wabbit season please
private message me so I can get your
contact details you can click here for
my non-spoiler e Justice League reaction
video and you can click here to learn
about all the Thor Ragnarok alternate
post-credit scenes and deleted scenes
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight